and the rife be used with pregnancy. Yes, we've always said that the rife is safe with pregnancy.
Now understand, if you google the rife with pregnancy, you may begin another
answer because a lot of things will define a rife machine differently.
If what a lot of people use a PEMF and they call it rife, so a PEMF is a post-electromagnetic
field therapy machine, that's electrical frequencies. Is our electrical frequencies okay with pregnancy?
Generally no, not over your uterus. So you have to be careful with electrical frequencies.
Could you use the PEMF on your feet? Yes, could you use the PEMF whole body at a very low dose,
low dose. Yes, but you would use a high dose PEMF over the abdominal cavity if you're pregnant.
So, but a lot of people will classify rife as electrical therapy. So we're talking rife,
we're talking about light frequencies with a plasma fill, Tesla tube. What you guys all know of
as a rife machine, well out there in the world, lots of people call all sorts of things by different
names. So, the rife machine that you have is what the acceptable for use with pregnancy.